so I just start off as starring this
movie affected your opinion on
technology or how you view tech computer
I I think living in the world of this
film made me realize just how vast and
deep you know the the world is of
technology and how it's impossible is to
be able to navigate all of the rabbit
holes that exist you know online how
much of your life do you find sort of
young you ated with sort of technology
more than I think I'm proud of saying
you know and that was the other thing it
you know we were watching watching it I
was like oh this is me this is oh I do
all of this and then you're like oh my
god I do do all of this like when am I
not on the screen sure you know and and
I think it does sort of sober you up to
think you know I have to be more mindful
of just the amount of time starting from
me how did this role sort of come to you
how did you get involved in the very you
know the standard way it came through my
my agent and I was offered the part and
Aneesh wrote a lovely letter with the
script and it was a very thoughtful
letter and then I opened it and I
started reading it and I thought what am
I reading what and so that really sort
of woke me up and then I realized that
really it was a classic suspense
thriller sure and I grew up watching
them like jagged edge and I thought oh
my gosh we don't make those movies
anymore why and it was it was exciting
to me and I related to the fact that it
was about a parent's love for their
child and about wanting to keep their
child safe I'm a mom I have you know
like my character I'm a single mom with
the son mm-hmm so that was really my
entree right in and then they were
twists and turns and then when I
realized this kid was 23
I just thought good you know this this
this is a visionary this kid is going to
be important in the future of filmmaking
and I don't know if this is even
possible for it to work but I don't care
if it works because I want to support
his very bold and very fresh idea and I
just want to be around it I want to I
found it very inspiring well how do you
sort of pitch you on the format did he
show you things or was there anything
you didn't show me anything no it was
you know I read it first
sure and you know and I've read it I did
I went back and I read it again and and
then we spoke okay and he was very very
articulate and passionate enthusiastic
and very clear and he felt very
sure-footed even though he was a
first-time filmmaker I just got off the
phone feeling like I'm in let's do this
I mean the whole film they shot 13 days
you know I was only there for I think
for five days I I don't understand how
it was possible but the whole thing you
know it was really because Annie's had
done his homework
and he came on set and he was
enthusiastic and and efficient and and
then they went away and he worked for
the editors for a year and a half and I
finally saw it and I thought oh my gosh
he did it mm-hmm it works it definitely
works yeah and then I got really excited
I got really excited well it's gonna
swen you first get a script like
searching how do you sort of prepare for
the character what's sort of the first
thing you do to sort of get into that
sort of mindset first thing I do is I
just try and see where I connect with
the character just in initially
immediately she had some sort of organic
level in this case I had been playing a
homicide detective on mysteries of Laura
for two years and had done a lot of
research
urghhh about that so I felt like I had
the groundwork about the life of a
detective and the effects on family
there you know the hours that they work
and and then I I got online and I looked
up you know missing persons and just
analyzed you know what the sequence was
what happens I looked at California and
and started to understand you know the
number of kids under 17 who go missing
and how many of them are Runaways and
how many of them are never found and
that was really sort of my jumping-off
point and and understanding from the
script that she was the best of the best
you know she had you know gotten awards
and commendations and so here was a very
confident you know professional sure and
and then I would just kept going back to
being a mother you know and thinking
about okay what is what is making her
make the choices that she makes do you
find there's a difference between
playing a homicide detective versus a
missing-persons detective are there
nuances there order um it felt very
different because we were dealing with a
child okay I think if we were dealing
with an adult it would have felt similar
in some ways because you know I think a
lot of times you're wondering if it was
a murder mm-hmm when if someone goes
missing but the whole child angle of it
really just it made this suspense
thriller emotional it had a heart
because there was a child involved I
mean most of them used acting up up
against a laptop what are sort of the
tricks to staring at a computer screen
look natural I don't know I can't even
tell you because it was the hardest
thing I have ever done
you know the reason why I love acting is
you get on stage and you have no idea
what's going to happen that thing that
happens between people and and that was
all yanked away and
just had a blank screen and I had his
voice in my ear and then I had an itch
in the other ear telling me where I
needed to put my eyes and keep it there
and and then action you know it was very
rigid technically and my character had a
whole other reality going on that people
don't know about so it felt it little it
felt like my imagination like my brain
was tired all the time just trying to
figure out how to convey all the things
that were going on in a way and to trust
that I you know that it was going to be
okay trust that and Anish wasn't going
to let me fail
you